Välkommen till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
I den här podden kommer jag träffa olika entreprenörer och profiler inom träningsbranschen.
Podden drivs av oss på gymkompaniiet.
Om du tycker om vad du hör får du väldigt gärna följa podden eller lämna en recession så att vi sprids.
Tack.
Ringde mina kollegor, vi ska stoppa en podd nu.
Löst det?
Vi börjar spela in på måndag.
Jag ska ringa Aftonbladet sen.
Ska jag hitta på ett namn i henne på podden?
Är det den bästa idé vi har?
Men det är inte den sämsta idé vi har.
Exakt, exakt.
Det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt.
Det kör vi på.
Det får det bli.
Klart, då går vi vidare.
Då säger vi välkommen till podden Daniel Richter.
Ja tjena tjena, jag blev lite nervös när du skulle tala efter namnet.
Har du inte gjort någon efterforskning på det?
Det är lugnt.
Jag funderade på bara säga Daniel eller Styrke labbet Daniel.
Ja, det är lugnt.
Jag hette ju Mattsson för typ nio år sedan eller någonting sånt där.
Sen så bytte jag namn när jag gifte mig.
Daniel Richter, före detta Mattsson, Styrke labbet guru.
Något åt det hållet.
Jag tänker att de flesta vet vem du är, men om man inte vet vem du är, skulle man kunna säga att du är grundaren och vd bakom Styrke labbet som är någon sorts evidensbaserad Wikipedia för styrketräning?
Ja, precis.
Jag startade 2011 bloggen styrkelabbet.se och några år sen blev det en podd och sen blev det en app.
Nu sprider vi ut oss åt alla möjliga håll, med engelsk sajt och medier och grejer.
Är den engelska sajten större än den svenska eller är den mindre?
Ja, den är större.
Den är tre gånger större eller någonting vid det här laget.
Vilket gick ganska fort där på slutet.
Många besökare varje dag från söktrafik.
I Sverige har vi fortfarande fler kunder än så länge.
Det är närmast i brytpunkten 50-50 inom Sverige och utanför Sverige så att säga.
Men fortfarande kärnfansen, om man ska kalla det så, är kvar i Sverige.
Men det är något vi kikar lite på att bygga upp utanför landets gräser också.
Just det.
Hur tänker ni att ni ska bygga upp?
Är det den engelska podden som dyker upp förr eller senare?
Det lutar mot det.
Vi jobbar på att testa en engelsk podd.
Har vi ett avslöjande från Styrke labbet inom två minuter på första poddavsnittet?
Om jag minns rätt så nämnde vi det här försöket i senaste svenska poddavsnittet.
Nej skit i dem.
Så jag tror inte att du fick scoopet.
Men vi sitter och övar lite grann jag och Filip.
Jag lyssnade lite men jag lyssnade inte alla fyra.
Nej, vi sitter och övar lite grann och preppar för att testa något sånt.
Vi kan liksom hoppa in åt dialet med en gång om du vill det men det är liksom en del i vår ansikte mot potentiella kunder och följare och läsare.
Så har vi haft sajten vi byggt upp under fyra års tid till att få snart en miljon besökare i månaden.
Ja det är mäktigt.
Men vi saknar, märkte vi då liksom, det här var inget som vi tänkte på förrän, men nu har vi pusslat ihop att vi saknar ett ställe för att fördjupa relationen med läsaren.
För söktrafikssite är väldigt såhär att man kommer in när man söker efter exakt det man vill ha och sen när man har fått det så sticker man därifrån.
Men det som vi då pusslat ihop efterhand hände i Sverige där vi först hade bloggen och sen poddade i sju år var att man knyter i ett väldigt starkt personligt band med någon som lyssnar.
En djupare relation helt enkelt.
Så det är det som vi nu lite kikar på.
Hur ska vi göra samma sak men för hela världen då?
Eller hela engelsktalande världen åtminstone.
Jag har lyssnat när ni har pratat lite om det.
Är det ändå ni tre som kommer köra?
Det blir jag och Filip blir det.
Sandrine backar du redan.
Så jag och Filip är det som kommer testa.
Jag förstår.
In Swinglish.
Ska ni ta in någon som faktiskt pratar engelska?
Det var förhoppningen för det.
Så fort vi översatte appen till engelska, vi har en styrketräningsapp för någon som inte känner till det, det heter Strengthlog där man kan logga sig i styrketräning eller följa ett träningsprogram.
Den är, jag lär mig aldrig, fyra eller fem år gammal vid det här laget.
Efter bara något år så hade vi översatt den till engelska.
Då sådde det sig fröt att det hade varit bra med en podd eller kanske en YouTube-kanal eller någonting på engelska för att marknadsföra den och hålla den i handen lite grann.
Då har vi alltid tänkt att det har varit bra med en som har engelska som modersmål som höjer de som är med.
Så att man övas och förbättras för det är svårare att lära sig av någon annan som är på samma nivå av er själv.
Men det har inte dykt upp någon sån och nu har vi väl landat lite grann i såhär fuck it, vi testar och ser vad som händer.
Kommer ni köra en remake på alla svenska avsnitt eller kommer ni bara börja nytt?
Nej, det blir nytt.
Vi har ett annat format, vi kommer börja mer liksom nischat med så smala avsnitt att här är en kvart om bänkpress i det här avseendet och här är tio minuter om det här.
Så att det liksom är såhär, man vet precis vad man får av rubriken.
Och sen då så kanske man förhoppningsvis kan vara personlig i de avsnittet samtidigt.
Att man utbildar er information men man vågar vara personlig och också berätta, det här tycker jag om det här faktumet eller det här misstaget gjorde jag relaterat till det här faktumet.
Att man vågar visa lite av sig själv samtidigt och där då börjar bygga den här relationen.
Ja, jag tänkte att vi kan sväva iväg här känner jag.
Det är några risker.
Jag vet hur du bara sitter och antecknar för din egen del.
Jag ska ringa Aftonbladet sen och lansera allt detta.
Så får vi lite scoop.
Jag tycker det är ett scoop.
Jag är väldigt fascinerad över hur livet kan ta lite olika barnor.
Och du pratade om i ett flertal olika intervjuer att från början var det inte bara Styrkelabbet som du började med, utan du hade lite andra tankar.
Kan du inte beskriva vilka andra tankar du hade och vart du hade kunnat hamna istället?
Ja, här behöver jag backa bakbarnet en bit men jag ska försöka att inte bli för långrandig.
Men redan när jag gick i mellanstadiet började jag ha sommarjobb på olika platser och hade det varje sommar genom hela skolgången upp till vuxen ålder och det blev helgjobb under gymnasiet och extrajobb under högskole tider och så vidare.
Så vi testade på väldigt många olika jobb i olika nischer, eller vad de ska kalla det, olika typer och kände nästan direkt att det här trivs jag inte så jättebra med, alltså byta tid mot pengar och där jag tyckte att den här timmen var inte värd.
De här pengarna, det skavde i mig liksom, hela det konceptet med det bytet.
Och även att man gör det för någon annans del, att jag bygger inte upp någon egen resurs i det heller.
Jag hade nog inte den benämningen på det tidigt, men jag kände att det här var inte riktigt vad jag trivdes med, utan jag vill ha något annat.
Men det tog liksom ett decennium att börja insätta att det finns något annat att man kan göra på andra sätt.
Och det var väl någon gång där i runt 20 års ålder som jag började insätta.
Förlåt nu avbryter jag, men var känslan att du ville ha, du ville skapa en Daniel Legacy, eller var det att jag vill ha ett softliv där jag inte byter pengar mot tid?
Alltså inte Legacy och inte softliv heller, utan snarare bara att det inte är så här jag vill liksom byta till mig pengarna.
Alltså att ge bort min tid så här, utan heller då att skapa någon egen grej som jag jobbar på för min skull också, som dessutom då ger lön nog att leva på.
Och det var, så har jag sagt några gånger, runt 20-årsåldern som jag fick upp ögonen för att internet finns och där kan man tjäna pengar.
Och började då liksom, alltså starta små projekt för att se hur tystnäck kan man göra det då.
Och då blev det efter ett tag olika sajter.
Det första var nog faktiskt, vid det här laget så var jag student på högskolan och läste till att bli brandingenjör.
Första sajten var nog bara en enkel reklamsida att anlita mig som brandingenjör.
Och vid det här laget så har det gått två år på högskolan och jag var absolut inte redo att jobba som brandingenjör.
Fick aldrig någon enda kund vilket var tur, men fick ändå insett att det här var nog inte rätt håll att gå åt.
Och sen så gjorde jag istället olika informationssajter som jag började med.
En av de första som blev några artiklar på varje sajt var löpning.
Det blev några andra småsajter.
Någon liten av styrketräning tror jag som jag släppte sen.
Du känns ju som en löpare.
Det känns ju som att du lever det.
Jag höll på mycket med det under gymnasiet.
Gymnasiet så sprang jag mycket.
Jag sprang Göteborgsvarvet en gång och sånt där.
Men så fick jag som hälften av alla tåndåringar, så fick jag diffus knäsmärta som varade i något årstid.
Då började jag gymma istället och sen släppte jag aldrig det.
Men jag gillar att jogga.
Vad tror du oddsen är att du och Filip hade blivit en duo om det var en löpsida?
Läge hade jag varit.
Något lägre.
Sen startade jag en sajt som var ganska kul som hette dubblingsleken.se som var att jag skulle dokumentera det här lite kända, det finns ett amerikanskt exempel en som genom byteshandel byter sig från ett plastgem hela vägen upp till ett hus.
Ja just det, för länge sen.
Genom att byta gemet mot en penna och penna mot en sax och så vidare.
Men där jag skulle börja med, det här var på tiden folk använde kontanter, så det första steget var att hitta en krona, vilket man gör typ så fort man går till en parkeringsplats på den tiden.
Och sen med den kronan då hela tiden dubbla sig upp, typ att köpa en klubba för en krona, sälja till en klasskombis för två kronor och så vidare.
Och där några tusen kronor upp i bloggandet på dubblingsleken.se så startade jag styrkelabbet.se som ett steg i den.
Om man skriver artiklar kan man dröja reklampengar.
Och det var väl också så här, jag hängde på träningsforumet Coliseum på den tiden och började se det här att det är samma frågor som ställs hela tiden.
Man hade kunnat samla ett bra svar av varje fråga någonstans och slippa repetera det.
Och insikta att många av de här grejerna kan jag ta reda på ett bra svar på.
Genom lite research eller redan kunnare.
Så jag började helt enkelt bara skriva artiklar på styrkelabbet.se om de här olika vanliga frågorna som dök upp eller vanliga problemen, glömde bort de där andra sajterna och så blev det styrkelabbet.se framöjent från hösten 2011.
Rätta mig om jag har fel, men sen skrev du Styrkelabbet under ganska många år utan att det egentligen, jag säger inte att det inte växte, men det slog ju inte igenom kanske på det sättet.
Hur höll du, vad hade du för tank där?
Nej, jag ska säga att vi hade lite tur för redan efter ett halvår, så fick jag ett väldigt bra kvitto från Google då, att trafiken svingade upp lite grann där runt januari-rushen nästan.
Och såg väl då att gör jag det här länge, så ser det ut som att det kommer att gå att leva på det här.
Men jag fick siffran för mig själv, att om fem år ser det ut som att det skulle kunna gå att få en heltidslön från det här, tyckte jag mig sen när jag var kanske något år in sen.
Men efter ett halvår redan fick jag en liten sån fingervisning om att det här verkar vara på väg åt rätt håll.
Och så fick jag fortsätta på det då.
Efter något år så handlar det väl om någon tusenlapp i månaden intäkter.
Men jag var fortfarande student här, så det var lugnt så länge jag visste eller trodde tillräckligt mycket, att det här är rätt sak att göra.
Men det var två år in som jag gjorde första produkten och säljade, inte bara dåliga annons-banners, som var en e-bok och direkt blev en halvtidslön, så det jag nästan gick att leva på.
Vid det laget så jobbade jag som brandinsjör redan efter examen, så jag stod på två olika platser under en tid.
Vad tror du gjorde att din hemsida slog igenom?
För att det finns ju otaliga människor som har tänkt starta den här sortens informationssidor.
Jag har fått genom åren många människor som har kontaktat mig och velat att vi ska ha reklam på deras sida eller att vi ska samarbeta med dem.
Du är ju inte ensam med den här idén.
Vad var det som faktiskt skickade?
Alltså jag tror, det är samma lite grann om man tittar på till exempel sociala medier, krimäla konton om ett visst ämne eller youtubekanaler om ett visst ämne eller poddar för den delen.
En faktor är förstås att det måste vara bra nog.
Det finns en tröskelig kvalitet som det måste över för att det ska funka.
Och då kvalitet, det måste ju inte vara att informationen är rätt, det kan vara underhållande eller någonting sånt där annars.
Men något mått av bra nog måste det ju vara.
Men sen tror jag att den absolut största grejen och det som skiljer de här 99,9 procenten som inte blir något från den promillen som blir någonting, det tror jag att man fortsätter, att man inte slutar.
Man producerar någonting tillräckligt ofta, tillräckligt bra och tillräckligt länge.
Och det är nog den största utmaningen, att ha den uthålligheten där.
Men var det en inställning redan från start, eller hade du släppt det om inte det där första halvåret hade visat sig funka?
Något kvitto behöver man ju ha för att se att det här verkar vara rätt grej, men så fort, det är väl min talang då den uthålligheten, men att så fort jag får någon vittring på att det här kan bli något, då är jag ganska uthållig att hålla på där, även om det tar många år att komma någonstans.
Det har ju återbjudit sig med andra släpp vi gjort, eller den engelska sajten till exempel, som hade fortfarande efter ett år väldigt lite besökare, men trenden var åter i tolv, fast det behövs många nollor bakom siffrorna.
Så det är väl lite det att man ska inte sitta och lägga flera år på att jobba på fel sak, men om man får teckna att det här kan faktiskt funka, då hänger det på att man vågar stå kvar där och gräva.
Var det så även med podden att ni gjorde några avsnitt, det gav inte riktigt och sen slog det igenom, eller var det bara direkt en succé?
Nej, den var mer åt det senare du sa, för då hade vi ju bloggat i fyra år.
Sociala medier var aktivt på ett annat sätt än vad det är idag, något mer av ett community tycker jag, på Instagram och liknande.
Men nu när du säger vi, säger du vi så som jag säger vi nu, eller menar du ja?
Nej, jag...
För jag säger alltid vi om den tidiga tiden, men det är bara ja.
Jag menar inte vi som jag är vän om, utan som är jag och Filip.
För det var vi som startade podden upp, och han var den andra personen in i styrkelabbet.
Men var han med och bloggade innan, var han med och skrev innan, eller kom han in på podden?
Nej det var han i och för sig inte, så då hade jag rätt i.
Då var det bara jag som bloggade, det är sant.
Men podden var annorlunda, för då släppte vi den till, får vi säga en målgrupp som var väldigt redo för den podden.
För då hade bloggen funnits så länge, men text är svårt att bli lika personligt som ljud och bild kan bli.
Så när podden kom, vi hade ju ett nyhetsspråk som byggt upp via bloggen, du vet att man hoppar på nyhetslistan för att få en bild från Knäby.
Ja det är nice.
De flesta har varit det.
Så där kunde vi säga att nu finns det en podd här.
Så den fick ganska många lyssnare med en gång.
Men då var det ju sitsen att då hade bloggen krattat man e skön för den och det fanns väldigt många som ville höra på en podd.
Kändes det lite märkligt att starta podden?
För att då blev du personlig.
Ja, jo men så är det ju.
Och det är ju förmodligen ett skäl till att väldigt många aldrig startar en YouTube-kanal eller podd eller någonting för att plötsligt blir du väldigt sårbar i att du säger någonting som någon tycker är skitkorkat och så vidare.
Och så är det ju alltid.
Och det är ju förmodligen också en av förklaringar till varför det landar mer kraftfullt hos lysstaren.
Att det är någon som vågar blotta sig och ta den här chansen.
Det känns ju inte som att ni har jättemånga haters.
Finns det det?
Jo, men det är ju många som tycker vi att vi är korkade eller att vi är för svaga för att prata om träning eller vad som helst.
Fast ni spöar ju mig och jag sitter ju och pratar nu.
Så då kommer jag få en full spara med haters.
Jag skickar fram Alexis på jobbet, han är stark.
Ja, nej men det dyker ju upp.
Men det får man ju liksom hantera genom att man helt enkelt är sig själv.
Det här är jag och det här tycker jag.
Jag gör ju inte anspråk på något annat och sen kan man ju inte göra så mycket mer.
Det finns ju det här, jag vet inte vem som sa det men att det enda sättet att inte få någon kritik är att inte göra något, inte säga något och inte vara någonting.
Det stämmer väl ganska väl.
Men har ni liksom folk som, jag ska säga, trollar i kommentarsfälten, vad är det här för sopor som, är det så?
Alltså vi har ju policyn att om man inte är artig då får man ju liksom inte vara med i våra grupper.
Man får jättegärna säga att vi har fel eller att man tycker annorlunda men om man beter sig dåligt då får man inte vara med.
Det ser inte jag av några konstigheter med alls liksom.
Sen på andra medier då, där man inte kan styra det, så har det väl varit några återkommande men nej, generellt har vi varit ganska förskonade, absolut.
Jag tänker om du ska vara lite icke-blygsam nu, för du sa att nästan alla har varit med på det här nyhetsbrevet, och det stämmer ju.
Jag vet att det stämmer.
Nej men det stämmer.
Vi har ju Colosseum, alla har hängt på det forumet någon gång.
Vi har Tyngre, alla vet vilka Tyngre är.
Och sen har vi Styrkelabbet.
Skulle du säga att du är topp tre påverkare av styrketräning i Sverige?
Det där är ju så svårt att säga, för jag såg här när du skickade över lite frågor, du ville snacka om innan.
Du får inte vara blygsan, du måste vara vad du egentligen tycker.
Ja men jag ska berätta vad jag egentligen tycker.
För du ska ju säga att du ville prata om bland annat om Styrkelabbet påverkan på styrketräning i Sverige.
Och jag funderar direkt på vad är orsak och vad är konsekvens.
För där med början cirka 2010 så kom det ju en styrketräningsvåg som var just där, skivstångsbaserade träningen.
Som liksom, jag undrar ju hur mycket är det så att bara jag och Styrkelabbet är ett symtom, alltså en konsekvens av den vågen.
Och hade det varit någon annan annars liksom, ifall det inte var det ni.
Så kan man inte resonera, det finns alltid någon annan som hade gjort.
Nu får du ju, nu blev det ju ni.
Nej men och då liksom, så uppenbarligen så är det ju, för att liksom vara på en svensk site med kanske 300 000 läsare i månaden, men det blir ju ganska många av de svenskar som är intresserade av styrketräning.
Det blir det ju, så där är det många som varit inne och har läst, absolut, och det är ju superkul.
Men jag tänker fortfarande att hade inte vårt sökerhetsresultat legat där, så hade de klickat på nummer två istället och läst nästan samma sak, fast det var en annan person.
Jag vet inte.
Det var ett politiskt svar.
Jag väljer att se det som att det är topp tre, under den här Jack.
Det får vi göra, får någon jävla måta.
I alla fall, bara för att förstå tidslinjen här.
Först kom hemsidan, sen kom hela bloggen, nyhetsbrevsgrejen, man fick ett litet program gratis.
Sen kom podden.
2015 tror jag.
Det brukar Filipson rätta med med årtalen, jag tror det.
Kunde ni helt plötsligt försörja er på detta då?
Två personer, blev ni sponsrade?
Hur funkade ekonomin i företaget?
Jo, men den var ett stort steg i det.
Det var nog så att vid den punkten 2015, fyra år in, då även om det hade varit kvar jag själv och inte startade podden utan jag bara hade bloggat, så hade jag nog ungefär där, velat ta steget och börja jobba heltid med detta ändå och säga upp mig som brandningsskör.
Podden var att det kom in ytterligare ett kort i leken, men det gjorde att det fortsatte åt samma trend och att även Philip kunde säga upp sig från sitt jobb en tid senare för att börja jobba med det här.
Det var liksom poddspons och pengar eller att vi kunde ha fler folk som ville köpa de väldigt få produkter vi erbjöd i tillfället.
Jag minns inte vad det var, det var väl några t-shirts, någon enstaka bok och så lite så här provision på kosttillskott ungefär.
Och hade ni en plan då eller körde ni bara på?
Det var nog inte så mycket plan utan mer köra på, men kanske så här att det i bakhuvudet fanns du vet en oformulerad tanke om att det här verkar gå och det kommer lösa sig, vi vet inte exakt vad vi kommer göra men man känner på sig att det här kommer funka typ.
Ibland så är det ofta så att man förklarar det för sig själv långt i efterhand vad som egentligen hände.
Det är lite så som jag tycker är jättekul nu med engelska satseringar att man får göra om lite av grejerna och måste fundera på varför blev det sådana olika saker då.
Podden är en sån sak som man insett att då får man just den här personliga relationen med folk och att det är en kontaktyta som vi saknar i vår engelska front just nu.
Kan du vara lite förvånad över hur väl en textbaserad hemsida har funkat med tanke på hur mycket text det borde finnas och hur mycket resultat det borde finnas på engelska?
Ja men det är jag, för när jag startade den engelska satsen av Strengthlogg det var ju, ja minst det den är snart 4 år för det var i januari 2020 då hade jag fokuserat så mycket på poddande i många år och inte skrivit så mycket så hade jag nästan glömt bort det som liksom är ditt och mitt, vad säger man, levebröd alltså SCO, sökmotoroptimering, jag började glömma vad är best practice, vad är grundläggande metoderna och fick backtracka och börja lära om lite och lära vad funkar nu och sånt.
Och märkte att det är typ samma saker och det går fortfarande jättebra att slås in på rankningen.
Det hänger bara på just tålamodet för det är liksom, du syns inte första året på deadlift.
När någon söker efter det.
Men nu syns vi.
Jag har kollat just idag, men vi är kring det här.
Men syns ni som att ni är topp på någonting?
Eller är ni ner och...
Ja visst, på massor av grejer.
Det är inte så illa.
Nej det är faktiskt, det var förvånande att det var så lätt.
Det var bara att jobba utan att få något tillbaka för det i flera år.
Så det är det som man får beredd att göra i många fall när det gäller organiskt marknadsföring, alltså som marknadsföring utan att man egentligen betalar för det.
Vilket jag inte har gjort så jättemycket.
Dels för att jag inte riktat kompetenser, och dels för att jag ändå känt att dit jag vill så, jag vet inte om det är liksom, det har inte varit ett viktigt verktyg vad jag plöte.
Eller det hade säkert hjälpt, men det har inte varit min kompetens helt enkelt.
På något sätt kanske du hade blivit lite lurad av det.
Eftersom hela er idé på något sätt är organisk tillväxt, så hade kanske ett betalt gjort att ni missade vissa detaljer.
Kan vara så och det hänger också på liksom, om man ska snacka business-termer, det hänger också på kundvärdet.
Om en kund värderar väldigt mycket pengar, då kan du betala ganska mycket för att få den kunden.
Som vi alltid har satsat på volym, alltså att varje kund motsvarar inte så många kronor kanske, därför de flesta bara konsumerar våra gratiske grejor, då kan man inte köpa sig till den trafiken heller, utan du får skaffa volymen till lägre kostnad så att säga.
Sen är ju kostnaden istället arbetstid förstås, så det är inte gratis ändå.
Men nej, men just bara det här med organisk marknadsföring, att ska man göra det, då ska man vara inställd på att det är årsskala man jobbar på.
Jag brukar se det typ som att första året, oavsett om det är liksom en YouTube-kanal eller en blogg eller vad som helst, en liten regel jag gjort upp för mig själv när vi sällan ser det nya organiska grejer, det första året så är det ingen som kommer lyssna.
Du står och pratar i en tom sal liksom.
Men år två, det är då det ska börja se att det här kan faktiskt gå, då ser du inga tecken på att det börjar lyfta då, då kan det vara felsatsning.
Och sen år tre, det är då du börjar komma in på det här, den exponentiella tillväxten har plötsligt fått rejäl fart och det bär sig själv då.
Det mönster tycker jag har återkommit många gånger genom åren, att det är ungefär den tidsskalan.
Och så fortsätter man sedan då bortom år tre.
Det är ett fascinerande långsiktigt perspektiv jämfört med hur många tänker idag.
Jag fattar att tre år kanske inte låter så långt, men det är ganska långt när man sitter där och malar.
Det är det och du måste ju hålla samma takt då hela tiden.
Så det har väl varit lite av min talang i det hela, att jag inte är smartast eller snyggast eller starkast eller någonting, men kan vara ganska metodiskt i alla fall, att hittar jag något som jag tror kan gå så klarar jag av att fortsätta göra det liksom.
Är du så i hela livet?
Nej, jag vet inte.
Det är svårt att säga.
Jag sitter i ett stökigt litet kontorsrum nu så, nej jag vet inte.
Fast stökiga skrivbord, det ska man väl ha.
Det är tidig, det köper jag inte.
Jag menar mer, när du och din, är det fru nu flickvän?
Ja, det är fru.
Sedan nio år tillbaka.
Snart tio.
Jaha okej, då så.
Grattis.
Tackar.
Var det så att när ni diskuterade, här ska vi flytta in, så sa du ja, om tre år ska vi planera ett äppleträd där, för då om åtta år kommer det vara ett äppelträd där, och sen funkar du så liksom.
Jo, men absolut, mycket så är jag nog.
Hon är också ingenjör, så det är ganska analytiskt liksom.
Herregud, vi hade aldrig kunnat umgås.
Jag är i totala motsatsning.
Jag ringde mina kollegor, vi ska starta en podd nu.
Lös det, vi börjar spela in på måndag.
Absolut, jag tror också det att vi hade varit som hund och katt i ett företag, vilket kanske varit bra, kanske varit dolt.
Så är det lite med Filip att vi är ju ganska olika, jag och han med.
Där vi då ser till att liksom, där en har styrkor får den liksom agera, och så backar man där den andra är stark liksom.
Det låter väl ganska rimligt.
Ja, det är mest bara att man måste hitta det där liksom.
Det kräver ju tid det är med.
Och fel steg.
Och också se det som positivt, eller att man kan jobba med det.
Ja, jo men verkligen.
Jag har flera frågor som jag vill följa upp lite med.
Om vi kör hela din engelska satsning nu, ni har byggt upp den, är du rädd för hela AI-boomen och att någon bara ska kunna mala 8000 artiklar om dagen på ChatGPT?
Ja, det gör ju folk.
Det är kul för det är ju nästan årsdagen nu när ChatGPT lanserades, nu när vi sitter och spelar in där.
Det var någon gång i oktober 2022 tror jag.
Så det blev offentligt kan jag säga.
Ja, ja men precis.
Så det har varit otroligt spännande att följa och jag var väldigt imponerad av det här när det kom.
Och så gick man väl igenom olika faser, du vet, som i sorgehantering ungefär.
Ja, vi har gjort samma sak.
Inte accepterat.
Och nu ett år senare så är jag ju på en ganska annorlunda plats mot vad jag var när det kom just då.
Och har testat en hel del och så vidare.
Så jag vet inte, kan inte du börja?
Jag vänder på steken en liten sväng.
Vad säger du?
Vi har faktiskt inte sett några negativa effekter alls.
Vi precis som alla andra, eller jag precis som alla andra, fick panik.
Gick in, satte två personer på heltid och bara mata genom olika artiklar och se om vi kunde täcka allt.
Vi slängde upp massa olika artiklar som var delvis inspirerade av detta.
Sedan kanske vi kom till någon sorts sans att det är lugnt, typ slappna av lite.
Sedan började vi känna av och vi trackade våra resultat jämnt såklart.
Vi är ganska stora inom SEO för just vår nisch.
Det som vi har sett är att nu har vi inte använt detta senast.
Vi använde det väl stenhårt i en månad och sedan släppte vi det lite.
Vi fortsätter uppåt i sökresultaten, vi gör som vi typ alltid har gjort.
Sedan är det klart att vi använder oss detta och ibland är kanske, har man skrivit om trisepsrepp 800 gånger och man ska lägga upp en ny produkt så kan man använda detta för att få lite nya idéer.
Men i övrigt jobbar vi relativt mycket som vanligt.
Det är det samma här.
Det är väldigt likt här.
Vi hoppar på i början för att se hur kan vi använda det här och försöka använda det.
Jag insåg rätt snart att nej, det här är de saker som är svåra för oss att göra.
Typ en text som är avancerad eller vad man ska säga.
Inte att den måste vara svårläst, men att den har ett annat djup eller en annan kvalitet i sig.
Så är det väldigt svårt att få en AI att göra det.
Om du får den att göra det så tar det lika lång tid som om du hade skrivit den själv.
Just textgenerering, då kan det vara till vissa enklare grejer.
Den kan vara jättebra på att göra en punktlista för om man behöver en ny text någonstans till hur utför man hantel flies, så kan man bera om det och det blir jättebra resultat för det mesta.
För den kollar på hur har alla andra miljoner PTS beskrivit det och så gör den det ungefär likadant.
Sådant små och enkla grejer eller om man behöver tips på rubriker och så vidare.
Men generera texter?
Nej.
Och vi ska komma tillbaka till texter men jag vill också nämna att det är så som jag använder AI idag, för det gör jag en hel del, det är på helt oväntade håll.
För det är till exempel i video-redigeringsverktyg så finns det AI-funktioner för att du brusreducera eller förbättra röst, alltså ljudspårskvaliteten och så vidare.
Massa andra sådana saker som AI gör som inte alls var vad jag trodde det skulle göra för mig efter ett år.
Så jag tror att vi kommer säkert att ha otroligt mycket nytta av AI och vi har säkert en massa hud i samhället och i tekniken vi använder som jag inte vet om alls.
Säkert min och din uppkoppling här är säkert AI-hjälpt av många olika sätt.
Men när det gäller just trafiken och SEO-delen, att man söker efter någonting och hittar något av kvalitet, så har jag tänkt att redan före ChatGPT så har Google haft en otrolig utmaning.
Det finns sådana enorma mängder skit på internet och det bildas sådana enorma mängder skit varje dag.
Så det sväller ju utan dess lika.
Där får vi att Google ett problem, även alla andra medier får ett problem.
Instagram och Youtube fylls av AI-genererade videos och ljudspår och allting nu också.
Att det finns miljontals bottar som sitter och producerar saker efter givna skript.
Och om man försöker då att tänka om man backar ett steg, vad kommer vara konsekvensen av det här?
Så tror jag att konsekvensen kommer vara en ökad betydelse av vad man skulle kunna sammanfatta som varumärke egentligen.
Att den där personen brukar vara vettig, jag lyssnar på vad den har att säga, eller det där företaget brukar ha kvalitet.
Jag liksom går igenom hela den här folkmassan av AI-skräp direkt till den källan för jag litar på den.
Alltså att man har, ja men varumärke har jag sagt, det blir en business-term, men det är helt enkelt en källan som man litar på att ha förtroende för att man vet att den, liksom när det gäller det här, så brukar det bli bra när jag lyssnar på den här källan.
Så det tror jag kommer vara en stor sak i framtiden.
Utbudet kommer bara att öka, det kommer bara att vara fler influencers, eller, jag bloggar inte så populärt längre men flera olika källor av alla de slag på nätet.
Så jag tror det kommer bli svårare att filtrera och då kommer människor att söka sig till kända punkter.
Och för att bli en sådan punkt så behöver du då kontinuerligt under lång tid visa upp de här kvaliteterna, som till exempel att informationen är korrekt, eller att du är trovärdig, eller du har praktisk erfarenhet, eller du gör produkter som håller måttet och så vidare, tills du liksom har förtjänat den platsen.
Det tror jag är fulgden av den här AI-genereringen av innehåll.
För att det är en ganska sund inställning.
Så vi kan alla slappna av lite.
AI kan fortfarande ta över världen.
Ja, eller slappna och slappna av.
Det som innebär är att det finns ingen gratis lunch.
Det är inget enkelt sätt.
Du kan inte bara köpa dig ett verktyg för 50 dollar som producerar 10 000 artiklar, utan du behöver faktiskt vara en bra källa.
Det blir ju ett livsverk egentligen.
Jag ska bara säga Daniel, jag ser att mötet avslutas automatiskt.
Ska vi då lägga på ringa upp igen?
Exakt, jag måste köpa pro-versionen.
Det var första gången jag körde till punkter.
Jag förstår det helt hållet för jag sprang in i samma grej när jag försökte göra Teams med dem.
Det är ingen aning.
Vi går in på samma läge.
Vi lägger på en lite svängare.
För alla som lyssnar så kan vi säga att det bröt sig där en liten stund, eftersom jag inte hade köpt Pro-versionen av Zoom.
Jag har varit i samma sitt som du, Tills.
Så jag förstår dig.
När jag var liten och naiv så tänkte jag alltid att företag skulle vara professionella, att allt var fixat, att alla hade koll på allting.
Det är ju inte så.
Nej, det inser man ju att det finns en miljard rörliga delar i företagandet, så att man förstår när någonting faller mellan stolarna.
Ja.
Jag skulle säga, har du gått igenom samma upplevelse?
Nu är ändå Styrkelabbet på väg att bli en internationell institution som tar värdkärra välde.
Är ni fortfarande ett gäng amatörer i en källare eller känner du dig som ett proffs?
Det är väl lite insikten att proffs är ju ett gäng amatörer i en källare.
Svaret är väl ja, alltså på bägge de liksom.
Nej men det börjar väl inse att vi vad våra styrkor är som företag och vad vi brukar klara av att göra liksom.
Sen så är det fortfarande så att för varje lyckat projekt vi liksom landsätter så är det förmodligen minst fem saker som vi väljer att det här funkar inte riktigt som vi trodde det skulle göra eller vi väljer att lägga fokuset här borta istället och så stryker det liksom.
Det kan vara satsningar på olika medier eller produkter eller liknande.
Kan du inte säga, för en av mina grejer när jag kollar på styrkelabbet är att det är så fruktansvärt linjärt och så här, att det här gick bra, det här gick lite bättre, det här gick ännu bättre.
Det känns som att ni har noll bakslag.
Nej men det ser jag inte, ta bara engelska sajter.
Kan inte du beskriva någonting som har gått dåligt?
Ja men engelska sajterna är en sådan.
För där startade vi ett halvår före strengthlog.com då, så startade vi en annan engelsk sajt, när vi kände att nu behöver vi börja bygga en närvaro på engelska internet.
Och det var strengthwiki.com, som var tanken att bli som en Wikipedia om styrketräning, olika muskler och sånt där.
Och vi började producera artiklar till den här och började väl få de första föraningarna om trafik.
Men vi började känna att det här inte riktigt är rätt, för det här blev för dålig koppling till vårt företag och vår produkt.
Och det blev liksom inget logiskt steg för en läsare där att glida över till vad vi var då för företag.
Så då gjorde vi liksom en pivot.
Och vi kände att det här var inte riktigt rätt.
Vi justerar, för det var inte så vi skrotade helt, men vi märkte att vi var lite fel på bollen och anpassade dem till att ha mer en traditionell blogg som Styrke labbet var.
Som ett exempel, det var inte att vi strökte helt men att vi gjorde så istället.
Ett annat exempel var att jag började satsa rejält på att försöka bygga upp twitterkontot för typ över ett år sedan.
Men började också säga att det är nåt riktigt rätt ställe.
Och sen efter, det kanske var två år sedan, och gick och grubblar i ett år och nu är jag satt på Instagram istället.
Det är fortfarande så att det kommer att kräva många år av att göra någonting för att verkligen få kvitto eller få resultatet.
Men under den tiden måste man fortfarande fundera på är det rätt sak jag gör då?
Är det här det som kommer att bli bra om många år?
Du beskriver ju hela tiden att, eller jag får känslan du säger, ja jag satsar på detta, jag satsar på detta.
Ni är ju ett gäng nu, du är ju vd i detta bolaget.
Och visst är ni typ åtta personer eller något sånt?
Ja, vi var åtta just nu, vi är sju och sen blev vi åtta igen, det börjar är ny.
En slutare gick till ett annat företag och nu får vi en ny i januari.
Plus en praktikant så nio då med studenten.
Men är detta din roll att producera content?
Är det där du vill vara eller är det där du är bäst?
Eller varför väljer du att ta den rollen?
Ja men jag tror det är där jag skapar mest värde för företaget nu liksom.
I viss mångs säger jag till folk vad jag tycker de borde göra.
Men ganska mycket är det utstakat redan.
Jag vill gärna ha företaget ganska decentraliserat.
Vilket innebär att folk har stort förtroende att fatta sina egna beslut i sina arbetsuppgifter.
Så jag växlar väl lite mellan att i perioder så funderar jag mycket på strategi och trend på internet och i folks beteende.
Vad är vi på väg och vad kommer folk att vilja ha om några år?
Och sen när jag tycker att jag hittar någonting då vill jag gärna gräva där.
Därför jag tycker att jag har vissa kvaliteter som gör att jag tror att vissa av de grejer jag kan göra bra.
Och då fokuserar jag på det.
Och så är det så då med vissa typer av innehåll skapar när man skriver eller poddar eller något sånt där.
Att göra det lite grann, om det ger resultat 1 kan vi säga, att göra någonting med en viss tidsmängd.
Om du dubblar den tidsmängden får du kanske resultat 10 000.
Det är en otrolig skillnad mellan att göra någonting djupt och att göra det bara lite grann.
Och där får jag försöka lägga den tiden att göra det djupt.
Vilket gör att andra saker faller bort och då behöver jag ha ett team som sköter resten av sakerna.
Och det blir liksom, ibland är jag som, då säger man, clownen i företaget för jag har inte koll på vad mina kvittorna är eller när någonting ska betalas.
Men det är ju egentligen ett väldigt aktivt beslut från mig att jag släpper allt det där för det här kommer att bli så mycket bättre om det får stort fokus.
Jag tror att det är en ganska sund insikt.
Jag tror det.
Jag tror att vissa typer av saker kräver den typen av fokus.
Ja exakt, exakt.
Det är det som är det viktiga.
Ja men Lisa istället för att...
För dig i alla fall.
Ja exakt, allting behöver skötas fortfarande.
Men istället för att jag ser till att mina kvitton ligger pressade i raka rader, så försöker jag se till att vi överhuvudtaget har några kvitton att jobba med.
Men visst är appen som är er stora business i nuläget, även om du jobbar med trafikan, skaffningen till appen skulle man säga, men är appen som är er bästa produkt?
80% av omsättningen och intäkter just nu.
Vilket också är en svaghet just nu, eller att vi borde ha fler produkter.
Det borde finnas en t-shirt att köpa också, för de som tycker om appen.
Eller oss.
Men eftersom vi inte har så mycket mer än text, så är det mest svenskarna som lyssnar på podden, som är fans då, en del är community, men det är det som vi vill börja rätta till med att göra det på ett språk som fler pratar också.
Inte för att det är något fel med svenskar men de flesta svenskar klarar engelska med, och vi vill ta det här ett steg vidare så vi provar väl att göra det på engelska istället.
Det kunde ni inte testa väl utan ni var väl tvungna att ta fram en live-version, lägga ner pengar och tid på det och sedan köra.
Eller kunde ni göra det på något litet?
Nej, utan det fick göras.
Men det var, magkänslan var att det här är rätt liksom.
Så jag hade ju kunnat visa att det inte var det, men det passade bra.
Det kom ju...
Och samma sak där, hur kommer det sig att den appen blev populär?
Det finns ju tusen appar att sälja in nu.
Nu får du skryta lite, det här är frireklam.
Alltså att det blev en app överhuvudtaget var ju att där...
Ja nu är jag fel på åren igen, men jag tror det var december 2018 vi släppte appen.
Det året och flera år före oss hade vi fått typ ett mail om dagen av folk som ville göra en styrketräningsapp med oss.
Men det var just Nils mail som var det bäst formulerade, som liksom gjorde att vi kände att hmm, ja varför inte det?
Så vi hade ett möte, sen så försvann han i ett halvår och gjorde appen och sen så liksom så här bonkade vi ut så att den blev så som vi tyckte det skulle vara också.
Och sen hade vi första lilla versionen av det, som vi kände var släpperedo.
Och varför den blev stor, men det var ju återigen då liksom att det var precis rätt produkt för vår målgrupp, som vi med lite tur då nu i efterhand, när vi försöker pussla ihop varför saker fungerade som de gjorde.
Att vi hade först haft då sajten och nyhetsbrevet, som gjorde att vi kunde få en poddcast, och liksom få en varm målgrupp så att säga, så en stor skara folk som lyssnade på oss och hade förtroende för oss, återigen det här med liksom att sticka ut i en värld av skit.
Att det fanns några som ändå tyckte att vi brukar göra bra saker, och vi har förtroende för oss.
Så att när vi då släppte en app så var det väldigt många som var beredda att ge den en chans, och den var tillräckligt bra för att det skulle flyga då.
Så det tror jag är den enkla förklaringen.
Jag kommer ihåg när ni lanserade den så var styrkevärlden täckt av det på Instagram.
Alla lukt de här bilderna och print-screensen, det var ju, man kunde ju inte vara inne på Instagram under den tiden.
Det är nice, och det är ju då en overnight success som är åtta år gammal, liksom, vilket är det komiska rörelser.
Det är alltid så.
Ja, det skedde ju för jobbet som hade gjorts före.
Exakt.
Ja, du är ju på något sätt förtjänad, eller ni hade det som karma, typ.
Ja, men jag, på ett sätt man vill säga att det är...
Ni har byggt en bas.
Det är arbetet innan förtjänade resultatet, eller förtjänade blir lite fel ord, men ja, jag tror man fattar mer om det här.
Ja, men jag fattar, ja exakt.
Ni hade lagt grunden för att det skulle bli...
Det skedde på grund av det som skedde.
Vi behöver inte vara så PK här, det är okej att säga.
Ni var grymma, ni lanserade en grym projekt eller produkt och det gick bra.
Det gick bra, ja det gick bra.
Alla kan göra det.
Vi är väldigt tacksamma över att det har gått bra.
Vi pratar lite om det i början med legacy-grejen där, eller om du ville tjäna pengar eller vad det skulle vara.
Är styrkelabbet din bebis eller din grej, är det detta du kommer göra hela livet, är det så du ser det?
Eller har du andra projekt du tänker, kan du ge oss en, såhär är det om 15-20 år?
Ja, det vet jag egentligen inte.
Det kan mycket väl bli att det blir styrkelabbet i decennier till, det kan bli att det är några år till för att någon vill köpa det eller vad som helst.
Det är egentligen inte det viktiga.
Om jag ska svara kort.
Och långt då?
Om du ska svara...
Vi har liksom inget mål, eller vi kan ha löst formulerade mål, att man vill att det ska bli en stor styrkertränningapp på hela världen, men det är egentligen inget mål vi berörs jättemycket om, för det är lite arbetärt.
Och flera av oss i styrkelabbet, i den lilla ledningen eller vad vi ska kalla det, är ganska medvetna om, jag citerar Karin Borgö, nog finns det mål och mening i vår färd, men det är vägen som är mödan värd.
Och det är liksom, för att ankryta till perspektiv, att det är liksom det arbetsdagen just nu som kommer avgöra hur lycklig och nöjd jag är med mitt liv när jag blickar tillbaka.
Det är liksom inte, det finns inget mål man når och då plötsligt blir man lycklig och nöjd.
Så fort du har alla dina basala livsbehov avhändertagna, då är det ju sen liksom det dagliga som är det som kommer styra liksom hur lycklig och nöjd man är.
Så vi har inget sånt mål för företaget utan målet är, dessutom för min personliga del, att mina dagar, att jag ska liksom vara nöjd med dem, att de ska vara så här, ja men det som gör att man blir lycklig över en dag, det är ju sällan liksom att det är dagen med de mest överdådiga middagar eller slapp och sånt där, utan ofta är det liksom jakten på någonting eller att man arbetar på någonting.
Man förlorar sig i jobbet eller man förlorar sig i sin hobby, i strävan efter något.
Så mitt mål är att få så många sådana dagar som möjligt och att jag hoppas att våra anställda också kan finna det här tillfredsställseln i det.
Känna att de får störa fritt hur man skapar värde till bolaget så länge det görs på ett positivt sätt så att man får en långsiktighet i det.
Det märker man väl när du pratar att det är hela det metodiska upplägget att se att det växer och det ska kännas som att det här blir större och större snarare än att det finns...
Jag ska ha tusen följare, jag ska ha 10 000.
Ja precis.
Det tycker jag går igen ganska mycket.
Men är det det som driver dig?
Det ska bara bli större.
Sen om det blir så större eller så större, det är inte...
I viss mån, för det har man sett att människor i allmänhet får en massa belörningshormoner i kroppen, när man märker att man kommer någonstans i ett projekt.
Fan jag hör, du har läst för mycket forskning alltså.
Om det så är snickrandet på din hemrenovering, eller det är webbtrafiken till din sajt, eller vad det är, att känna att man gör framsteg i något som också är lite utmanande, det är typ det som gör en lycklig.
Det är det, och så är det relationer med andra människor.
Det är sånt som gör människor lyckliga.
Då handlar det bara om att hitta ett arbete där man får den här känslan.
Ja, jag vet inte om detta är sant, men jag har det någonstans i bakhuvudet.
De gjorde någon forskning på en massa människor då, och om man levde länge, eller ifall man var lycklig när man var gammal, den enda faktorn de hittade var om du har många goda vänner så går det bra.
Ja, det verkar vara superviktigt.
Det är en av de stora sakerna som människor trivs med.
Där har jag som introvert hemmajobbare alltså utmaningar att jobba med.
Där mår jag bra av relationer, men har också ett stort behov av att vara på min egen kant och fokusera själv länge.
Men absolut.
Ni sitter fortfarande hemma allihopa?
Nej, vi har rätt Stockholmskontor nu där de är tre just nu och blir fem snart.
Nyss hade vi Göteborgs kontor och Stockholmskontor, men vi flyttade upp Nils då där Filip och Sandrine sitter.
Så vi har samlat några av oss lite mer.
Men du ville stanna kvar?
Ja men jag bor ju nere i Stångby, nära Lund.
Här bor jag med familj och barn och allting sånt där.
Men det är lite, som du nämnde, man blir lycklig av relationer med andra, det sätter också finger på att vi kommer inte bli gladare för att vi når x-antal användare i appen.
Det är inte det man blir glad av.
Så fort man når det, det är som med styrketränning, så fort du bänkar 100 så vill du bara bänka 102,5.
Och bryr dig inte om den gamla gränsen längre.
Så ju för man kan få den insikten, desto snabbare kan man då sluta jaga felmål.
Det var ju lite grann den här kopplingen då när jag började sommarjobba som barn och kände att jag vill inte byta timme mot pengar.
Jag vill få in de här pengarna på något annat sätt istället.
Och sen började jag märka att okej, det är inte pengarna som kommer göra mig glad heller.
Hur fan blir jag nöjd då liksom?
Och så den sökandet hela tiden, att blicka inåt lite grann, att vad tusan vill jag göra egentligen.
Och den är väl livslång egentligen också den här jakten och sökandet, men man försöker komma en bit längs vägen bara.
Ja jag tror att när den jakten och sökandet slutar, då är det nog inte så roligt längre.
Det är ju frustrerande men man måste ha den känslan.
Jo men precis, det är i alla fall vissa av oss.
Där är det nog du och jag lika.
Ja det är det enda jag tänker på.
Jag tänkte hoppa in på några sidofrågor som vi inte har täckt av, som jag ändå tror kan vara lite intressanta innan vi fastnar i.
För det känns som att din sidokarriär skulle kunna vara någon sorts livsstilcoach slash filosofer, men inte det podden är.
Så jag vill höra, du är ändå Daniel Richter.
Hör du efternamns...
Ja det tar sig.
Du kan säga amerikanska, det säger man Richter.
Richter, ja.
Det är sådana här folk som säger Joel på engelska, det är skitklångligt.
Men nu är det ju en känd Joel i The Last of Us.
Jag följer ingen.
Det är den enda serien jag har sett sedan Game of Thrones.
Annars så finns det inte tid för sånt.
Jag vet att om jag säger här att jag inte kollade Game of Thrones eller så blir jag lynchad.
Men det kanske är för att då var du redan igång jobbat en kommende jag var student fortfarande.
Så då fanns det en möjlighet.
Det kanske var så jag var yrkesverksam och ansträngde mig för att göra världen till en bättre plats.
Ja men du har rätt.
Jag offrade mig själv.
Skitsamma, det är inte det vi ska prata om.
Vi ska prata om dig och dig.
Du kommer in på ett gym, alla vet vem du är, kan du träna där och känna er lugn?
Tänk om du gör fellyft.
Ja, nu är jag i en särskild sits där.
Jag är ju äntligen sedan vi flyttat till hus och fick barn, vi har tre barn, de är två, sex och åtta år gamla.
Jag gjorde ett hemma gym i garaget i samma veva.
Dels för att kunna träna på ett tidseffektivt sätt, slipper gympendlingar och allt sånt där, men också för företagets skull för att kunna filma övningar och videos och sånt i det garaget.
Men det gör ju då, och det här återkopplat till det där du nämnde om ett lyckligt liv, att jag tränar hemma själv.
Jag kommer ju väldigt sällan till ett gym och träffar massa träningskompisar.
Dels för att det inte finns möjlighet att köra de här tre timmars styrkelyftspassen längre än när man jobbar av karlfamilj och prioriterar jobb och familj högre än träningen.
Det går inte att motivera det lika ofta, inte just nu med småbarnsåren i alla fall.
Dels är det lättare för mig att sticka ut 30 minuter på lunchen i gymmet än att sätta mig i bilen eller på tåget och ta mig till ett gym nån annanstans.
Så jag hamnar inte i den sitsen så ofta.
Men när jag väl gör det, ja absolut går det att göra det.
Jag har haft några år på mig att vänja mig vid ögonen.
För när podden var som störst, när den var på sin peak kanske runt, 2017-2018 eller någonting, då fick vi doppat håna i kändiskap.
Egentligen så fort vi gick utanför dörren i någon lite större ort så var det ett par personer som stoppade både mig och Filip varje gång.
De mötena är kul, det är inte så, men jag känner ju att att vara känd, det är inget för mig mer än så.
Kändiskap är verkligen ingenting som jag strävar efter, mer än att om det kanske hade varit användbart för företaget.
Men för min personliga del så är jag bara tacksam om jag är okänd.
Jag kan ju tänka mig vilket fängelse det måste vara för folk som är kända på riktigt, om jag jämför med min lilla nivå, där det ändå blev en hel del egenkänning.
Är du ändå en god och trevlig människa i det normala livet?
Eller behöver du anstränga dig bara för att folk har ögonen på dig?
Lite grann får man väl snäppa upp sig att inte stå och peta näsan mitt på stanen.
Men det är väl ganska lugnt.
Men man har det bakhuvudet mindre nu när kändiskapet minskat för att vi gör andra saker.
Men risken är väl att det kommer tillbaka då.
Men jag vill poängtera att de som kommer fram det är inte till besvär, utan det är mer fenomenet som jag reflekterar över.
Jag fattar.
Man är kanske mitt i någonting, man ska också prata.
Man har sitt personliga liv och så är det någon som tittar på en.
Ja exakt.
Man får skilja på personlig och privat.
För i vår podd och i mycket av vad vi gör anstränger vi oss för att vara personliga, för då knyter man ett band.
Man visar sin åsikt, man ser vara sårbar och så vidare.
Men det är skillnad på att vara personlig och privat.
För privat är när jag berättar på mina barnheter och vad de gillar att göra eller vad jag har svårt för.
Eller vad min fru gjorde häromdagen eller sådana saker.
Det är en annan sak.
Och då, om man är i sitt privat liv, så blir det plötsligt ett möte mellan de två världarna.
Ja, full förståelse.
Speciellt om man har tre små barn, de kanske skriker, du kanske är mitt i din, kanske inte bästa situation i livet.
Är det två du har nu eller?
Ja, två.
En 1,5-åring och en 3,5-åring.
Ja, det är spännande.
Det är inte ordet jag skulle använda.
Jag är väldigt fascinerad över att du valde att välja tre.
Jo, det fick det allt vara.
Men nu börjar jag känna mig ganska nöjd.
Jag är väldigt tacksam över att jag jobbat hem under den här tiden.
Och då, lite medvetet också gjort av allt.
Jag hade ju kunnat sätta mig på ett kontor och träffa mer människor, men prioritera barnen här än så länge.
Och få också lite bättre fokus så länge barnen är på förskolan.
Men i trion, familj, jobb och träning så har jag liksom, när familjen kom in i bilden, då var det träningen som fick stryka på foten.
Men den började återvända mer och mer nu eftersom barnen blev äldre.
Hur hanterade du den mentala inställningen?
För att jag har givetvis gjort samma uppoffring, eller vad vi ska kalla det.
Jag bestämde mig när barnen kommer och när de börjar ta över tiden, då är det givetvis träningen som får stryka.
Men det är lite ledsamt att känna år för år att man blir sämre, sämre, sämre.
Samtidigt så måste man ju göra så, annars är man ju en assholefarsan liksom.
Ja och man måste ta hand om de anställda liksom.
Alltså jobbet är ju vad det är, relationen är vad den är, barnen är vad det är, det är ju träningen som får stryka.
Ja exakt.
Nej men det är klart att det kräver att man klarar av att acceptera det.
Du är ändå en metodisk person som vill utveckla sig.
Ja men precis som även liksom både du och jag älskar ju träning, så det hade väl vi kanske tur att det gick bra för oss att acceptera det, för någon annan kanske det har varit mycket svårare.
Men jag har också sett det som att dels att jag vet att jag kommer att få träna sen, och jag har aldrig haft någon sikt på att bli någon mestare ändå.
Jag vill fortfarande bli bättre, jag känner att jag kommer inte vara nöjd om jag inte gör ett ärligare försök, att bli ännu lite starkare.
Men det har inte värst att min karriär har hängt på att jag tar ett VM-guld eller någonting sånt där direkt.
Och dessutom så har jag också faktiskt tänkt på att det här är ju den sitsen som typ alla jag pratar till, alltså i min roll som utbildare eller vad vi ska kalla det.
Så det här gör ju bara att jag får mer förståelse för de allra flesta jag pratar med.
Så det har jag kunnat säga som en positiv sak, att hur är det för den som jobbar 8-17, har några barn hemma, är också intresserad av att träna?
Hur kan man få ihop det då?
Jag tror att det är ganska sunt att, eller i vårat företag så var det jag som fick barn först, och sen nu har jag två tillfått och en är på väg få.
Det var tur att jag var först.
Du hade inte varit så förstående annars.
Nej, nej nej nej.
Eller för mig har det alltid varit, alla jobbar alltid jämnt.
Och nu är det typ, kan jag ta en halv dag här?
Det är klart att jag kan ta en halv dag.
Bara ta en hel dag.
Ja men det är skönt.
Jo, jag tror samma.
Det är bra att veta vad det handlar om.
Särskilt om man då ska anställa i den sitsen.
Det måste vara tufft tänka och gå igenom riktigt hårda småbarnsår och ha en chef som är helt oförstående för att ha barn.
Det kan vara tufft.
Ja, det funkar inte.
Det är nog tur att vi bor här där man får ta pappalediet eller mamalediet som man vill.
Det är det.
Det är inte dumt.
Men jag tänkte fråga, du jobbar ju som jag ganska fritt, eller vad jag ska kalla det.
Däremot så jobbar man alltid.
Ja, så är det ju att det är...
Hur har du hanterat den, speciellt du jobbar hemifrån?
Du är ju helt körd.
Ja, så är det ju.
Jag har läst, det var på Twitter, jag följde en kille, tror jag han hette Johannes kanske?
En typisk framgångsrik SEO-are som bollar väldigt stora siffror.
Han skrev någon tweet någon dag som verkligen fastnade mig så jag minns det nu.
Som företagare eller i vissa andra jobb så kommer du alltid ha mycket att göra.
Du kommer alltid ha mer att göra än vad du hinner med.
Och om du låter det stressa dig så betyder det att du kommer alltid vara stressad.
Slut.
Så då blir det en perspektivfråga.
Man har den här oändliga mängden arbete framför sig.
Man kan alltid skriva en till artikel för att få fler besökare.
Eller göra en till reel till Instagram.
Men om jag då ska gå och låta det stressa mig under 10, 20, 30 år till av arbete där i hemmet så dömer jag mig ju till ett liv av stress.
Det är faktiskt ganska stor skillnad för mig att nej, nu får jag backa ett steg, vara nöjd över det jag gjort och chilla lite grann.
För att det här kommer inte att funka annars.
Så det är väl mitt sätt att hantera det.
Ska vi säga att det är lätt att säga, svårt att göra?
Ja, absolut.
Ofta är det så här att om man liksom hittar sitt scen, är det sin mindfulness där man kan acceptera det här, så ofta blir det att det tristar upp sig med tiden ändå.
Eftersom månaderna går, får man lägga till arbetsuppgifter eller klämma ur sig lite mer, tills man börjar nå problempunkten och så får man backa bak lite.
Men återigen det blir en fråga om acceptans.
Det går inte att göra mycket som helst.
Och också det här att fatta att livet är just nu, det är arbetsdag för arbetsdag, eller dag för dag.
Men de flesta är ju arbetsdagar nu då.
Så därför har det alltid varit viktigt för mig att fundera på hur jag vill att min dag ska vara.
Och jag vill inte gå runt och vara stressad en dag.
När jag kan göra exakt samma arbetsuppgifter och känna en jättestor glädje över det och en väldigt stor meningsfullhet och tacksamhet att få göra dem, så kan jag ju bara genom att skifta perspektiv göra samma saker under en dag men vara superstressad.
Och det är inte så smart.
Det känns som att du är relativt duktig på att välja att det är den här världen jag vill ha.
Ja men det är det.
Jag funderar på hur jag vill ha det och så försöker jag väl ta mig dit.
Sen ser utmaningen och lyckas lista ut vad man vill ha.
Ja det är ju en svår fråga men om någon har frågor om processen och hur man ska tänka då får de kontakta dig.
Ja.
Jag tänker som sista avslutande fråga, hade det varit väldigt kul att höra, du jobbar inom träning och hälsa fast inte som PT eller skapar ett gym, det är som man kanske spontant tänker på när man tänker på den världen.
Har du några tips på hur man kommer in i träningsvärlden och faktiskt kan försörja sig på det?
För det finns så många som försöker men som aldrig kommer till försörjningsdelen.
Nej och det är ju, i allmänhet är det nog en ganska lågbetal yrkesgrupp tror jag.
Alltså att vara tränare i allmänhet, även om du börjar vara tränare för lag eller liknande.
Men det handlar ju hela tiden om kombinationer.
Att om man då väljer, du ska kombinera upp två saker, den ena är träning, men kombinera ihop den med vadå då?
Vill du stå i ett gym och vara PT?
Vill du skriva böcker om det så att du är en författare och träningsintresserad?
Vill du göra poddar, vill du göra video?
På ett eller annat sätt behöver du få tränning kombinerad med någonting för att det ska bli något sätt att leva på det då.
Det kan vara att du är idrottaren själv och försöker tjäna pengar på det på något vis.
Så det finns en massa olika saker du kan välja och där får man väl börja fundera på vad är en styrkor, vad gillar man att göra och så vidare.
Jag är ju introvert och behöver ganska mycket tid för mig själv för att ladda mina batterier och det kan vara ganska dränerande för mig att hålla en PT-timme med någon.
När jag har kört PT hemma i mitt garage, då är det en timme i veckan jag kör med folk som jag bokar in och det räcker gott och väl för mig.
Det tycker jag är jättekul men jag hade aldrig klarat att köra tio timmar om dagen med någon, då hade jag gått in i väggen direkt.
Däremot så är det andra som jobbar som PTs i gym, de hade blivit fullständigt knäckta av att sitta och bli ett tangentbord flera timmar om dagen och läsa någon tår text och skriva en ännu tårare text.
Så det handlar om att hitta var ens egna intressen och styrkor där för att kombinera dem.
Så jag tänker att man ska inte fastna vid att det bara är PT man kan vara och inte bara att vara gymägare man kan vara.
För båda de skulle jag säga är ganska nischade egenskaper och nischade personlighetsdrag man behöver ha för att trivas med det.
Jag gillar det.
Det finns en bok, jag tror den heter The Medici Effect eller något sånt.
Och den handlar om hur man kombinerar två olika områden för att skapa någon sorts excellence då.
Det är lätt att göra ett område, det är lätt att göra ett annat område men när man kombinerar dem.
För på något sätt beskriver du att för det är väldigt lätt att tänka på träning, då tänker man det här.
Men man får ju tänka på träning kopplat till någonting, eller på något sätt, eller att man gör det genom ett viss sätt som kanske ingen annan har gjort, eller som man är stark inom då.
Och det har ju aldrig funnits bättre möjlighet att livnära sig på träning på något sätt än det gör idag.
För varje år ökar chanserna liksom.
För det här att det finns många influencers, eller många bloggar eller liknande, det ska man se som ett positivt tecken.
Om det finns många sajter om styrketräning, då betyder det att det finns många som vill läsa om det, det går att tjäna pengar på det.
Om det är tomt någonstans, man ska bli lite orolig.
För då kan det vara att man har väldigt fel i sin satsning.
Det kan vara rätt att man blir den första där, men att det finns mycket konkurrens, det ser jag som en bra sak.
För då funkar det fortfarande.
Jag får väl säga så här Daniel, det har varit en yndest för mig att lyssna, att få ta del av din samlade kunskap här.
Jaha, det var trevligt.
Att få lyssna på en av de stora.
Ja just det, det var du då, inte mina.
Jag säger dem gärna.
Ja, men det var ganska trevligt.
Fantastiskt.
Väldigt roligt att få vara med i är det.
Och jag är jättetacksam för att du ställde upp.
Jag hoppas att det kanske finns någon som är ungefär i den sitsen jag var för, 15 år sedan eller 20 år sedan eller någonting, och går och grundar den här.
Det finns nog ett tiotalstusen som hade behövt höra några ord.
Ta till sig av din metodik eller hur metodisk du är, det kan många ta till sig av.
Ja och det är ju då min grej, och någon annan har kanske en annan grej.
Så man får liksom spela med korten man har fått.
Jag köper det, samtidigt kommer alla att behöva jobba länge under lång tid för att faktiskt uppnå någonting.
Absolut.
Vi säger nog tack där tror jag.
Ja tack själv, det var trevligt.